Вітаю! Я Леонід Горобець,
доктор біологічних наук.
Сьогодні проведу урок на тему:
"Антропічний вплив на атмосферу".
Поширена думка, що життя на планеті Земля
завдячує своїм існуванням гідросфері.
Частково це так.
Якби не було води, то не було б і життя.
Однак не варто забувати, що наявність
повітря є не менш важливою складовою.
Без атмосфери життя
також було б неможливим.
Тому вкрай важливо слідкувати за станом
атмосфери, щоб вона була не забруднена,
інакше – життя на планеті припиниться.
Більше того, якщо людина може вибрати:
яку саме їй воду пити,
які продукти споживати, то ніхто
не в змозі контролювати в повній мірі,
яким повітрям він буде дихати.
На жаль, ситуація із забрудненням
атмосфери в Україні не найкраща.
На мапі показано
забруднення атмосфери у містах.
Бачимо таку сумну статистику, як
кількість смертей на 1 мільйон жителів.
Найвищий показник – це понад 400 смертей
у рік на 1 мільйон жителів.
Україна – з-поміж лідерів.
Звичайно, як видно з мапи, серед країн
із найбільш чистим повітрям,
переважають країни із
слабо розвинутою промисловістю:
країни Африки, деякі країни
Південної Америки,
хоча у Венесуелі
промисловість розвинута непогано.
Однак тут є і досить розвинуті країни.
Наприклад, Намібія – країна
цілком благополучна
і не тільки в економічному плані,
але і в забрудненні атмосфери.
Переважна більшість
промислово розвинутих країн
мають ті чи інші проблеми із забрудненням.
Це ж стосується і курортних країн,
таких як, наприклад, Болгарія чи Румунія.
Як бачимо з мапи, у містах цих країн
стан атмосфери не найкращий.
Одним із поширених
забрудників атмосфери є пил.
Пилове забруднення може бути двох типів –
– або природне, або штучне.
Природне, наприклад: пил від вулканів;
пил, який розноситься вітром,
або навіть пилок від рослин,
може здійснювати помітний вплив
на довкілля.
Так припускають, що занепад цивілізацій
у XII столітті до нашої ери
був зумовлений посиленням вулканічної
діяльності в регіоні у ті часи.
Є й приклади з більш сучасної історії.
Так у 1815 році відбулось
виверження вулкану Тамбора в Індонезії.
Воно було настільки потужним,
що впродовж 1816 року
трималися досить низькі температури.
Цей рік увійшов в історію як рік без літа.
Зауважу, що вулканічна діяльність
не припиняється.
І в подальшому, можливо, навіть завтра,
станеться повторення року без літа.
Пилок для багатьох жителів планети
не становить великої небезпеки.
Це цілком природній складник,
який звичний нам,
і наш організм на нього реагує
без особливих наслідків.
Та деякі люди мають алергію на пилок,
і він їм суттєво дошкуляє.
Найбільш поширена кількість людей з
алергією проживає саме в містах.
І в часи, коли починають квітувати
ті чи інші рослини,
Їх життя суттєво ускладнюється – включно
до того, що дехто змушений сидіти вдома.
І якщо пилок від деревних рослин:
пилок берези, вільхи, граба тощо –
– алергію на нього ще можна лікувати,
то на сьогодні ефективне лікування
алергії від трав не розроблене.
Також важливим фактором
пилового забруднення є діяльність людини.
В першу чергу – робота різноманітних
будівельних підприємств,
каменеобробних підприємств,
гранітних кар’єрів тощо.
Коли кам’яні брили
переробляються у жорству,
в гальку тощо, то довкола розлітається
велика кількість пилу.
Дрібні шматочки пилу проникають у
наш організм і осідають в легенях.
Особливо погано те, що вони фактично
не реагують із нашим організмом,
а, відповідно, не можуть бути
виведені з організму.
Дрібні кристали можуть залишитися
в легенях на все життя.
При цьому вони механічно пошкоджують
клітини легень і можуть стати причиною
смертей або різноманітних захворювань.
Також розповсюдженню пилу сприяє знищення
поверхневого шару ґрунту людиною.
І в такому випадку дрібні частинки пилу
розлітаються довкола, псуючи нам життя.
Звісно, що важливим чинником забруднення
довкілля є хімічне забруднення.
Якщо оцінити у відсотках, скільки газів
викидають форми людської діяльності,
то на першому місці стоїть
теплоенергетика,
далі йде автотранспорт,
не менш важливим забруднювачем є
виробництво будівельних матеріалів,
кольорова металургія, нафтопереробка
і хімічна промисловість вносить відносно
небагатий вклад у забруднення
порівняно із теплоенергетикою або
автотранспортом.
З газів, які виділяються в атмосферу
внаслідок людської діяльності,
у першу чергу варто відмітити
вуглекислий газ CO2
У таких концентраціях, у яких
виділяє промисловість,
він не становить жодної загрози
безпосередньо для організму.
Впродовж останніх 150 років,
внаслідок людської діяльності
вміст вуглекислого газу зріс на 0,02%.
З точки зору організму – це
вкрай незначне підвищення.
Однак не варто забувати, що
вуглекислий газ є парниковим газом,
тобто він здатний утримувати тепло.
Підвищення кількості
вуглекислого газу в атмосфері
сприяє підвищенню температури на планеті
і стає наслідком глобального потепління.
В результаті цього суттєво змінюються
кліматичні системи в регіонах:
можуть виникати засухи або навпаки –
раптові повені, зливи
та інші численні негаразди.
Окрім того, глобальне потепління
призводить до танення льодовиків,
у першу чергу в північній півкулі. Та,
південна півкуля страждає також,
щоправда, у трохи меншій мірі.
І це може мати наслідки не лише тому,
що зникне середовище, де мешкають
пінгвіни чи білі ведмеді,
але і в глобальній перебудові
всієї планети.
Прісні води, які утворюються від
танення льодовиків Гренландії,
цілком спроможні впродовж XXI століття
зупинити хід Гольфстріму і
Західна Європа буде недотримувати
тепле повітря.
Як наслідок,
у Західній Європі може виникнути
суттєве похолодання,
в той час як на всій планеті буде
глобальне потепління.
Розглянемо вплив деяких форм діяльності
на людський організм по окремості.
У першу чергу згадаю теплоенергетику
та автомобільний транспорт.
Основна шкода від теплоенергетики,
крім того, що виділяється вуглекислий газ,
є те, що при спалюванні вугілля,
в атмосферу виділяються
сполуки із вмістом сульфуру.
За певних кліматичних умов ці сполуки
можуть контактувати із водою
в навколишньому середовищі,
перетворюючись в сульфатну кислоту.
Кислота
в повітрі представлена у вигляді дрібного
аерозолю і людина, вдихаючи повітря,
вдихає також цей аерозоль кислоти.
Вона осідає на легенях,
руйнуючи клітини легень.
Зокрема, в 1952 році в Лондоні мав місце
"великий лондонський смог".
Внаслідок цього смогу впродовж двох
тижнів від захворювань дихальної системи
в Лондоні померло більше 2 000 людей.
В подальшому, впродовж місяця
кількість жертв зросла до 4 000.
Появі смогу лондонського типу
сприяють певні погодні умови.
Зокрема, для нього необхідне холодне
повітря – приблизно від 0 до +5 градусів С
та висока вологість повітря,
в середньому – вище 70%.
Смог лондонського типу може виникати
не лише в Лондоні, а в будь-якому регіоні,
де використовується теплоенергетика і
спалюється кам’яне вугілля.
А таких міст чимало в Україні.
Інший смог – смог лос-анджелеського типу –
виникає внаслідок інших причин і
виглядає зовсім інакше.
Першопричиною смогу лос-анджелеського
типу є викиди автомобільного транспорту,
в яких наявний високий вміст
оксиду нітрогену.
Потрапляючи в навколишнє середовище,
за певних погодних умов
він може перетворюватися в
нітратну кислоту.
Цьому сприяють такі погодні умови, як
яскравий сонячний день,
тепло
+25-30 градусів С
та відносно низька вологість повітря –
менша 40%.
І тому смог лос-анджелеського типу
виглядає значно позитивніше –
сонячно, тепло, добре, не так похмуро,
як при смогу лондонського типу.
Однак, попри те, що
візуально вони різняться,
негативний вплив на організм у них
приблизно однаковий.
Нітратна кислота у вигляді аерозолю
осідає на поверхні легень
і руйнує наші клітини, призводячи
щороку до смерті багатьох людей.
Смог лос-анджелеського типу виникає
не лише в Каліфорнії.
Зокрема, він досить чисельний в Києві,
оскільки Київ розділений Дніпром,
посередині якого
виникають потоки повітря,
що ускладнюють перемішування
повітря над містом.
Як наслідок, виникає невидима стіна,
яка розділяє правий і лівий берег міст
Київ, Дніпро та інших.
Внаслідок діяльності автотранспорту,
повітря затримується або над правим,
або над лівим берегом, замість того,
щоб розповсюджуватись по атмосфері міста,
поступово розсіюючись.
І в результаті цього страждають
деякі жителі міст України.
Смог лос-анджелеського типу є проблемою
в деяких розвинутих регіонах Європи,
зокрема у Баварії, яка знаходиться у
природній заглибині.
Ускладнене перемішування повітря,
оскільки це заглибина.
Але велика кількість
автомобільного транспорту,
Адже Мюнхен є однією із
автомобільних столиць світу.
І тому, поїздка в Баварію у липні або
у серпні – це далеко не найкраще рішення.
Окрім викиду оксиду нітрогену,
автомобільний транспорт
"збагачує" повітря
іншими шкідливими речовинами,
серед яких особливо варто було б
відмітити сполуки плюмбуму.
Зокрема, вздовж автомобільних трас
вміст плюмбуму може в 10 разів
перевищувати допустимі концентрації.
Також в атмосферу викидаються
різноманітні вуглеводні,
альдегіди і далеко не такі приємні як,
наприклад, ванілін,
а такі як формальдегід, який є
вкрай небезпечним,
а також – бензопірен, який є
дуже потужним канцерогеном,
тобто він сприяє розвитку ракових пухлин.
Окрім того, бензопірен є ще й мутагеном,
тобто сприяє появі мутацій, що може
мати негативні наслідки для нащадків.
Тому вкрай обережно треба ставитися до
автомобільних трас:
уникати пробіжок вздовж автотрас,
прокладати маршрут ближче до парків,
природного середовища тощо.
А також не варто
вдаватися до таких форм підзаробітку,
які пов’язані із перебуванням на трасі.
Наприклад, вкрай популярний спосіб
серед молоді –
стояти із рекламним транспарантом того чи
іншого магазину біля тієї чи іншої траси.
Звичайно, що це легкий спосіб
підзаробити певну кількість грошей,
але наслідки для організму будуть
надзвичайно шкідливі.
В молодому віці це, зазвичай,
не відчувається,
оскільки багато з цих сполук,
зокрема, сполуки плюмбуму,
не безпосередньо впливають на організм,
а спершу накопичуються
в червоному кістковому мозку.
Однак із віком, внаслідок
слабшання організму, різноманітних
стресів,
недосипання тощо,
сполуки плюмбуму виходять із червоного
кісткового мозку і починають діяти,
руйнуючи наш мозок, кістки, зуби,
органи кровоносної системи тощо.
Таким чином, підзаробіток у молодості,
або, навіть,
здається, спроба вести
здоровий спосіб життя,
може мати небезпечні наслідки
у подальшому.
Те ж саме стосується
альдегідів і бензопіренів,
оскільки вони підвищують ймовірність
розвитку ракових пухлин,
яка реалізується не відразу, не того дня,
коли ви пробіглись, або стояли з плакатом,
а через декілька років або
декілька десятків років.
Звичайно, що чимало хімічних забруднювачів
викидає в навколишнє середовище
промисловість.
Ніхто не буде сумніватися, що
хімічна промисловість,
нафтопереробна промисловість тощо
супроводжується викидами
різноманітних небезпечних сполук.
Навіть такі, здавалося б,
безпечні форми діяльності
як то целюлозно-паперова промисловість.
Папір – що може бути природніше і
нешкідливим, папір легко
розщеплюється в навколишньому середовищі.
Яка небезпека від його виробництва?
Навіть целюлозно-паперова промисловість
може мати негативні наслідки.
Зокрема, для того, щоб папір став білим,
в багатьох випадках використовується
штучне відбілювання паперу хлором.
Викиди хлору надходять в атмосферу
і впливають на мешканців навколишніх міст.
Результатом цього є порушення
серцево-судинної діяльності,
що може стати причиною інфаркту,
а також – головний біль,
руйнування зубів тощо.
Тому треба бережливо ставитися до паперу.
Часто ми нехтуємо цим і використовуємо
папір для того, щоб його зім’яти,
намалювати якийсь нічого не значущий
символ і викинути,
роздрукувати те, що можна було
прочитати з екрану тощо.
Однак варто пам’ятати, що
всі форми діяльності
тією чи іншою мірою забезпечуються
у сучасному світі промисловістю.
І тому необхідно зважувати,
а чи потрібна мені саме в цей час
та чи інша форма діяльності, навіть
якщо це просто зминання паперу.
Згадаймо, що особливою формою
забруднення є фізичне забруднення.
Нагадаю, що це ті форми забруднення,
параметри яких мають енергетичний вимір.
Більшість проявів фізичного забруднення
добре відчутні на прикладі атмосфери.
Теплове забруднення, що виникає
через діяльність різних промпідприємств,
у першу чергу реалізується у тому, що
вони нагрівають повітря довкола себе.
І це може мати негативно впливати
на мікроклімат міста.
Окрім того,
варто пам’ятати про світлове забруднення.
Споконвіку Земля оберталася навколо
сонця і оберталась навколо своєї осі.
Внаслідок цього, добові і сезонні ритми –
це є основними ритмами на планеті.
І майже всі жителі планети, окрім хіба що
жителів глибин та печер,
у тій чи іншій мірі адаптовані до
змін дня і ночі.
За сприйняття світлових променів у людей
відповідає особливий орган – епіфіз.
Він знаходиться у мозку,
в глибині мозку.
Однак світлові промені доходять до нього
і завдяки цьому епіфіз приймає інформацію
про тривалість дня і ночі,
про зміну світлового дня тощо.
Він виділяє гормони, які
регулюють нашу діяльність.
Вплив епіфізу добре відчутний на
погіршенні настрою у листопаді й грудні.
Здається, погода у грудні й листопаді
особливо не відрізняється від лютневої -
так само прохолодно, вогко,
хмарне небо тощо.
Однак у листопаді та у грудні
світловий день скорочується,
епіфіз підмічає це скорочення і виділяє
меншу кількість певних гормонів –
внаслідок цього погіршується наш настрій.
І ті речі, які нам здаються у
лютому чи березні
якоюсь несуттєвою дрібничкою,
у листопаді чи грудні можуть
сприйматися, як справжня катастрофа.
Існує гіпотеза, що наявність веселих свят
наприкінці грудня –
таких як Різдво, Святий Миколай,
Новий Рік тощо,
є не випадковістю, а спробою людей
хоч чимось розрадити грудень.
Отже, як бачимо, світло має досить таки
помітний вплив на нашу діяльність.
Однак слід врахувати, що людина може
штучно змінювати освітлення.
Це може бути використано на користь –
можемо штучно подовжити світловий день
і при цьому уникнути нестачі
освітлення у грудні.
Однак можна і перебільшити.
У тому випадку, якщо ми не
дотримуватимемося світлового режиму,
будемо вмикати світло в 3 години ночі,
будемо активними в 3 години ночі,
або навпаки – спати о 12 годині дня,
коли навколо все світло –
епіфіз відреагує на це і порушиться
гормональний фон організму
із багатьма витікаючими наслідками.
Найбільш простими наслідками може бути
погіршення настрою,
розвиток виразки шлунку, гастрити тощо.
Та деякі наслідки можуть бути і більш
негативні, як то розвиток ракових пухлин.
Зокрема, помічено: порушення
добового режиму – у жінок
у 4-ри рази підвищує ймовірність розвитку
раку молочної залози.
Рак молочної залози – це лише
один із прикладів.
Взагалі вчені вважають, що порушення
добового режиму
впливає на ймовірність розвитку
ракових пухлин і в інших місцях.
Ще одним проявом фізичного забруднення
атмосфери є електромагнітне забруднення.
Воно може бути цілком природним.
Так, в 1859 році, внаслідок потужних
вибухів на Сонці,
сталася так звана подія Керрінгтона.
Електромагнітна хвиля великої сили
дійшла до Землі,
внаслідок чого зросло електромагнітне
напруження поля Землі.
Проявом цього були численні спалахи
полярного сяйва
в цілком помірних і навіть
субтропічних регіонах.
Навіть відомо, що в цей час у Каліфорнії
о 4 годині ночі прокинулися золотошукачі
і почали розводити вогнища для
приготування сніданку.
Сяйво довкола них було таким сильним, що
вони подумали – настав ранок,
а це була лише 4-та година ночі.
Якби подія Керрінгтона сталася у
наші дні, це була б справжня катастрофа.
Перегоріли б абсолютно всі
електромагнітні прилади на планеті:
смартфони, інтернет, банківська система -
все б абсолютно вимкнулося.
Звісно, що це була б катастрофа
неймовірного масштабу.
На щастя, вона сталася у середині XIX
століття, коли електроприладів було менше.
Та немає гарантій, що вона не повториться
завтра, післязавтра, через тисячу років.
Сприяє електромагнітному забрудненню
і людська діяльність.
Наші міста насичені електродротами,
електричними приладами тощо,
які збільшують електромагнітне напруження,
і це також впливає на наш організм,
і може проявлятися в погіршенні настрою,
або ж у згаданих раніше
збоях у роботі шлунково-кишкового тракту
чи серцевої системи.
Ще одним фактором фізичного забруднення
атмосфери є шумове забруднення.
Воно найкраще проявляється в містах,
оскільки у сучасному місті
надзвичайно велика кількість джерел шуму.
Часом вимірюють шумове забруднення
або в герцах, або в децибелах.
Спецпрограми, які дозволяють виміряти
шум у децибелах, є в багатьох смартфонах.
Але варто враховувати, що
шумове забруднення складніше
і воно залежить не лише від частоти
чи від сили звуку,
а залежить одночасно і від показників,
які вимірюються у децибелах,
і від показників, які
вимірюються у герцах.
І той, і інший показник однаково важливий
по їхньому впливу на наш організм.
І також, звичайно, варто згадати
радіаційне забруднення атмосфери.
Радіація зазвичай асоціюється із
чимось техногенним –
ядерною зброєю, вибухами на
атомних електростанціях тощо.
У світі чимало місць, забруднених
радіоактивними відходами
антропічного походження.
Однак переважна більшість радіоактивних
ізотопів осідають або в ґрунті,
або в гідросфері,
що є темою наступних уроків.
Що ж до
радіаційного забруднення атмосфери,
то переважна більшість
радіоактивного фону у повітрі
формується під впливом природних чинників.
Із них на першому місці – газ радон.
Нагадаю, цей газ виділяється із
материнських порід – граніту, базальту
та всього, що зроблено із
граніту і базальту.
Зокрема цементу, бетону, асфальту,
бруківки тощо.
Оскільки ми живемо у кам’яних,
бетонних будівлях,
гуляємо по вулицях, які вимощені
бруківкою або викладені асфальтом,
то газ радон оточує нас довкола.
У нормальному стані його концентрації
не перевищують допустимі межі
і радіоактивний фон зберігається
у межах норми.
Та нагадаю, що радон - досить важкий
і під час провітрювання приміщення
радон останнім покине територію,
оскільки він є найбільш важким газом
у складі атмосфери.
Для вивільнення приміщення від радону,
недостатньо привідкрити кватирку,
тим більше недостатньо провітрювання
за допомогою кондиціонеру.
Час від часу необхідно відкривати вікно
і впускати порції свіжого повітря.
Якщо ж не вдаватися до цього, то
у мало провітрюваних приміщеннях
радіоактивний фон може
підвищуватися в декілька разів.
А, оскільки ми живемо у наших будинках
впродовж десятків років,
то з часом це може стати причиною
різноманітних захворювань.
Так, за даними Всесвітньої Організації
Охорони Здоров’я,
недостатнє провітрювання приміщення
є причиною 25% випадків раку легень.
Джерелом підвищення радіоактивного
фону атмосфери є ультрафіолетові промені,
які надходять від Сонця.
Існує думка, що перебування на Сонці
робить наш організм здоровішим.
Таке уявлення виникло в XIX столітті,
коли одна частина людей –  аристократія,
одягалася так, що фактично
недоотримувала сонячного проміння.
Інша частина людей, зокрема, пролетаріат,
постійно перебував на підприємствах,
мав короткі відпустки і, як наслідок,
не відпочивав на природі.
Тому вони також недотримували
сонячного проміння.
Внаслідок цього і в аристократії,
і у пролетаріату
виникали хвороби, зумовлені недоотриманням
кількості сонячних променів.
Однак ці проблеми в минулому.
Сучасна людина з її способом життя,
з тим одягом, в який ми одягаємося:
легкими футболками, майками, шортами...
отримує цілком нормальну кількість
ультрафіолету, і зловживати цим не варто.
Якщо ж все-таки вдаватися до
надлишкової засмаги,
не берегтися під час прогулянки у горах,
де дуже високий вміст ультрафіолету,
або ж гірше: зловживати соляріями, тобто,
штучним використанням ультрафіолету
всі ці фактори можуть стати причиною
різноманітних хвороб.
У першу чергу – раку шкіри,
який лікується надзвичайно важко.
А ось і дзвоник. На цьому у мене все.
Будьте здорові!